oh my god please someone help anyone
please hey I heard you screaming my name
is Zoe I just heard you and I wanted to
say hey what's that you know my leg is
caught between a bike I think I think I
broke it
oh yeah that looks pretty bad
don't get any of that
are you crazy please just help me call
9-1-1 my dogs making some important
calls right now so are you serious
come on just help me or get someone
please we may have to find some better
solutions to make you feel better maybe
we can play a game of chess and I'll let
you win please I don't want to play
chess I just want to get out of here
please help me hurt okay I'm being very
kind here you can have my Polaroid
camera okay that doesn't work maybe then
I have something for you please I don't
want your stuff
are you hungry sir Oh Sean made it hurt
maybe maybe you're interested in in Zoe
the second please just help me get
someone else please I know I got it it's
always a genius I'm gonna sing you a
song
oh really please just get me out of here
stars shining bright above you night
breezes seem to whisper
[Music]
gosh he fell asleep to my angelic voice
I should help people for a living
fine I'll take
start shining bright above you night
breezes seem to whisper I love you
[Music]